let's go and reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
this red bed extended diner scene from
the movie bright bird I'm really much
looking forward to this film how about
here John yeah I think it looks pretty
cool yeah enough catch up before we go
into this I wanna say thank you to
everyone who's been following us over at
our patreon page over there we do weekly
Q&A as well as TV show reaction stream
along for many shows that includes my
hero academia one punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood picked up the
latest season of attack on Titan man
that seasons good The Haunting a
Hillhouse Cobra Kai season two latest
season of Game of Thrones and
supernatural several other shows have
reaction highlights included that's Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia one punch man its latest season
an attack on Titan and supernatural and
he also has music video coverage this
guy this rock star over here
ooh
Gary's really really fast she was four
o'clock text we're really feeling this
whoa snakes on a plane Oh
there yes yes first thing
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
did he pull it with his mind it was
actually cool look at that because that
scene we've seen in this shorter version
on the trailers pretty much that whole
thing this movie clip doesn't feel like
edited down no no I'm taking out
timeline so it was cool to kidding kind
of get a feel for its tone in these kind
of sequences and stuff well I wasn't
like this feels so entirely unique and
different in terms of the way the
sequence is playing out you know like
okay are the signs and the walls for
some reason she's like is that you Gary
come on you know no way I don't know who
Gary is or who she's referencing I'm
like there's no way to tell you
everything that's Gary yeah I like the
POV where it was one I was cleared the
other I was ready cuz even in one shot
where she couldn't see the kid we could
see the kid in the background I'm really
excited for this movie I'm looking
forward to it I kind of confused that
I'm the kids powers now I thought it was
just a riff on Superman but it looked
like with the door you know when he did
the laser thing to it and then it pulled
it away did he like pull it out and then
go back there and stand or did he use
his mind to pull out the door sort of
telepathic yeah door ripping yeah I get
the sense that he's just kind of
all-powerful and I guess in the Superman
metaphor at this point I've come to
assume that yeah it probably has all
kinds of powers and I hope the movie I
assume the movie will be clear with what
they are but yeah that was what I liked
the most about this is the level of
horror that they honed into with this
because you really do feel awful for
this waitress here and I loved yeah that
trick with the POV you get that really
nasty you know full-on shard removal for
a while I was like we're really feeling
I was really a lashing this Janna and
and it looked good it looked convincing
and and yeah I really liked that kind of
split screen effect with the red and the
even the way they muffled her breath
when you go into the POV and I like that
they may committed to that as sort of a
motif of the scene and gave it kind of
not that it is found footage because it
is POV but I gave it kind of a
found-footage aesthetic feel I think
this movie looks cool but I haven't been
overly like excited I gotta see it you
know it makes a cool premise and I'm
waiting to see if this will make a truly
satisfying feature film but I thought
this sequence was pretty cool and and it
added something to it from you know the
times I've seen imagery yeah it's a good
sequence because like I was trying to
say earlier you saw this sequence really
edited down in like 20 to 30 seconds in
a trailer format you know sometimes when
you you know like oh that seemed look
really cool the trailer then you go
watch the actual movie you're like yeah
like the tone and everything did it
really - it seemed like it's really well
executed I feel like some people might
take getting this whole scene with this
waitress getting murdered at the diner
seeing this whole thing play out as a
bit of a little much you know - really
especially to release online yeah who is
she
why is the marketing so intent on
showing her how did she get slaughtered
is this like it's cool a sequence out of
the movie Sony Pictures I often question
the way they market sometimes you know
yeah well I wonder if maybe this is just
one of their few scenes that doesn't
have like a bunch of very important like
you know if this is a death that maybe
isn't overly important to the rest of
the plot or something maybe this is a
scene that it's not gonna spoil much but
it's still cool and indicative of the
style the movie that they can show us
either way this is a weird thing to wake
up at 8 in the morning to start the day
well that's the other thing too is I
guess I was expecting this clip to be
scarier but I think because we've seen
this scene already yeah like a few times
and countless times in the theaters now
the effect of it has been a little
watered down but I still got a plenty
from it to go yeah this is just more
confirmation for me that this is
probably gonna be an effective movie
yeah yeah when I like the clip took its
time I mean that was a that's really the
only new thing I got out of this is like
okay here's a better sense for how the
film itself might move it might yeah or
more of its time it might play up on the
suspense side more than just the
aggressive we're gonna show you cool
exploitable elements is pacing in town
means a lot this seemed to have both of
those down pretty well yeah well what
did you guys think of this bright burn
clip before I wrap this video
I would like to give a patient the day
shout out part two for Victoria Huntley
now last month we totally missed her
shout out so this is your part to form a
right here Victoria here's what I'm
hoping for you my dear you are engaged
meaning you will be married one day and
when you be married you be having
children and I pray to God you get one
of these kids
this kid is loyal to mommy you're gonna
want a kid who's that loyal and if you
get a [ __ ] waitress that kid will take
her out do some of the UK so you know
there's plenty of like rude waitresses
you got a sick your demon child on yeah
because that's one thing why every day
is famous for its it's bad customer
service so you take advantage of that if
you do have a kid like this I hope you
use him to you know maybe help old
ladies cross the street you know rescue
cats from trees and not murder people in
Lin freezers unless it's youtuber Tyrone
Megan oh yeah sure you put that Jairo
needs to go he's too big
he's too powerful only your son can stop
look I know this wasn't great this was
when you come by it was hard white it's
pretty cool you guys to subscribe to the
react nation click the notification bugs
you guys soon